Speaker 1: All right. On Monday, I told
you some states are looking very strongly
at going in the direction of considering dropping
mask mandates, either indoor at businesses and
or in schools. Over the last 48 hours
since I came to you with that report,
it is accelerating dramatically. More and more
localities, more and more states talking about
no more masks as of some date in the relatively
near future could be February could be March.
And the question now is, is this the right time?
Not everybody agrees that it is. I don't actually
have an answer. And so anybody trying to read into
whether I think it's time to end masking or not,
I'm not completely sure. I think there's
definitely a discussion to be had. Let's
go through some of the news. ABC reporting
indoor masking coming to an end in New York.
Is it hopeful or hopeful? I never remember Hochul
expected to make an announcement Wednesday. It is
anticipated that the governor of New York will
announce the end of the indoor mask mandate in
New York state on Wednesday, but the city mandate
will remain in place. The state mandate requires
masks to be worn inside businesses where
vaccination status was not being checked.
It is set to expire Thursday, and the New York
Times reports that the governor will rescind it.
Connecticut and New Jersey are already
among a handful of states with plans to
ease ease mask mandates in schools. The governor
of New York has not made the same move. However,
she held a call with school superintendents
who believe an announcement is coming soon.
The governor is expected to extend the mask
mandate, passed its February 21st expiration
and through winter break. Meanwhile, Illinois
is expected to announce an end or rollback
of certain mask rules. CNN reporting the governors
of New York and Illinois are expected to announce
the end of or a plan to roll back certain COVID
mitigation requirements involving masks today.
I already told you about New York. In Illinois,
Governor J.B. Pritzker will likely announced
Wednesday a path for ending the state's
indoor mask mandate in most public places.
There is also increasingly pressure in
Massachusetts on the Gov. Charlie Baker
to make some kind of off ramp type statement. Many
cities and towns already going in that direction
in California, California's indoor mask mandate
will end next week for vaccinated people, citing
a 65 percent drop in COVID cases since the peak
of Amick Run. California will end its statewide
indoor mask mandate for vaccinated individuals
next week. Gov. Gavin Newsom announced Monday
on Feb. 15, California's statewide indoor mask
requirement will expire. Unvaccinated people must
still wear masks indoors. Less than 20 percent
of the state's population remain unvaccinated,
according to data. The Biden administration
has not yet offered a plan or roadmap for how
to handle this, so a couple of different things
here. Number one, not everybody agrees about this.
One example is the former Surgeon General
Jerome Adams. Now, Jerome Adams was not
exactly the voice of reason when Donald Trump
was president. So there are people who would say,
I don't care what Jerome Adams says, but Jerome
Adams tweeting quote, I respectfully disagree
with many of my colleagues who are espousing the
idea that prematurely dropping mask mandates will
somehow make it easier to bring them back if and
when things get worse again. How'd that work out
when CDC said vaccinated could unmask last summer?
He went on to say, how do I define premature?
Well, by looking at spread impact and protection
spread seven day average still highest since April
of last year, impact over 2500 deaths yesterday.
Protection only 22 percent of those five to 11
and 56 percent of 12 to 17 year olds
are vaccinated. Exit the highway early
trip takes longer. I'm not sure if this is the
right thing to do or not. On the one hand, Jerome
Adams is right, which is the numbers are still
not looking great. That being said, we know that
the numbers significantly lag what is going on.
There are states with cases down 85 to 90 percent.
Vaccines are so widely available, the death
rate is so incredibly low for the vaccinated
that there becomes a question of what is the
milestone. And if there is not a reversal,
if we say, well, cases are down in the country,
about 70 percent in some states they're down
85 to 90 percent. If we give it one more month
and that continues and there isn't a reversal.
There really won't be anything else to wait
for in the sense that it's not going away
anytime soon. There's going to be a low level
again if in the next month there's not a new
variant that causes cases to spike in a month,
cases will be really at what we might call an
endemic level doesn't mean the cases are mild.
It might or it might not, but we're talking
about the case levels. There's a question of what
would we be waiting for at that point in time?
And there's not really a clear answer. And so
that's where the if not in two to four weeks,
then when becomes a relevant question. People who
choose to remain unvaccinated do so at their own
risk. And as always, the question then becomes
What about the immunocompromised? And that is a
situation where those folks say, Well, I've gotten
vaccinated, but I still really can't do anything
because I might still catch it and I'm at higher
risk. And that's a serious question. I mean,
a lot of those people haven't been doing anything
anyway. So it is a sort of chicken egg thing where
if the immunocompromised folks that
have been staying home all this time
are already staying home, then what is the reason
to delay ending the mask mandates for those who
are not staying home? It's complicated. I'm
going to admit that it's very complicated,
but the question I keep coming
back to is, if not in a month,
then what is the milestone that we are waiting
for? And I've not heard a good answer to that,
which suggests continuing on with some of
this stuff. The schools question is a separate
question, particularly when in schools you've got
a population that has a lower vaccination rate.
I'm thinking out loud along with you guys, and
I know that in my audience there are people who
are saying, This is it. It's time for the personal
responsibility phase and everything and let people
decide for themselves what level of risk to accept
like we do during flu season. Some people already
would wear a mask during flu season or stay home.
That one side of my audience, the other side of
my audience says, Do nothing. We need to keep
masking for at least the entire year. We should
be closing schools. We should. So so I know that
there's different sides in my audience, and I'm
curious to hear from you. Find me on Twitter at
David Pakman and let me know what you think should
happen now. I know most of you probably don't know
this, but we are an audience supported program and
I would love it if you supported us through our
membership program at join Packman dot com. We
have so many great membership perks, including
a daily bonus show which Alex Jones hates.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you
want to make money and everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: We also have commercial free audio
and video streams of the show available
for our members every day. And you get
the show six hours earlier. You know how it
normally at 9:00 p.m. Eastern. That day's
full episode is out in video format. As a
member, you get it at three p.m. Eastern
six hours earlier. Stunning, stunning stuff.
And you can sign up at Join Packman dot com.